I remember nine years ago when I started
that alley pay people say yet
don't touch the financing sector because
it's illegal you may be in prison if you
want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories as the Aintree
premier you have to get used to be
challenged have to get used to be said
no by the other people we have like a
300 people become millionaires and I
asked them eight now tell me you become
millionaires because you are smarter
than the others the people said no no no
we even get out by the jobs
Oh
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get used to rejection when I didn't
graduate from universities and before
you know for three years I tried fill in
two universities so I applied jobs for
30 times that reject it
I went for a please listen no you're not
good I went to you know even the KFC
when KFC came to check up do I say you
see 24 people went for the job 23 people
accepted I was the only guy and we went
for please five people all of them
accepted I was the only guy in
aristocracy better so to me being turned
down rejected oh by the way I told you
that I would apply for Harvard for ten
times rejected I know ten times you
wrote them and said I'd like to come to
Harvard yeah
and then I told myself somebody I should
go teach there buddy also if you want to
have more confidence check out my 254
series it's free the link to join is in
the description below
it's so difficult to be it took me five
months to bond five hundred dollars the
people who do the bottom should believe
in the model and I believe what I do
rule number two keep your dream alive I
have a secret code for global success
just like Open Sesame is a secret code
for Alibaba the secret coming for
everybody's keep your dream alive
because it might have
this is worthless Siri cookies rule
number three focus on culture what do
you think your core competence is I'll
call its culture it's not the technology
I think technologies are to the core
competence of our companies we have 220
Fowler grow from 18 people to now to
define young people and we focus a lot
on the value in a mission and making
sure the culture everybody work for
helping others instead how instead of
you know just to make you money rule
number four ignore the little Maine
people don't like it so many people I
talked to at that time for Ollie pay
they say this is the stupidest idea you
have ever got but I say I don't wear the
stupid it club as long as people use it
now we have 800 million people using
this a leap a good number five get
inspired I learned a lot of things from
from movies I learned how to make a
speech from the movie code bodyguard
Whitney Houston when she sings the Suns
I look at her wow that's the way that
you make a speaker because I never know
how to make speech because I'm a not
actor but when I saw the movie I said
wow if you sing from your heart if
you've seen naturally if you your cure
yourself so I I realize and I learn a
lot from the movies you know even learn
from the Godfather's I learn my favorite
movies the Forester gum you know these
these are the things I learned so much
then I will discuss about the muse the
inspiration so we got from movies rule
number six stay focused
what kinds of business ideas have you
said no to I'm saying no to a lot of
ideas because as a CEO I have to say no
to opportunities because if I say yes I
probably got a five thousand
opportunities every day but where the
years are know everything based on the
meshing that we
helping is doing business easier if it's
on that would consider if our somebody
come in saying can you will you don't
have does it you will make a lot of
money I'm not interested rule number
seven have a good name
why did you call it a la Baba Alibaba
well when I started I think internet is
below but we should have a global name
and I named that interesting like at
that time the best ur name is Yahoo
right I think I can so I've been
thinking for many days suddenly Alibaba
is a good name so I I was happened to
being sent San Francisco that day never
didn't have a launch and the waitress
can I ask him do you know about Alibaba
should you say yes I see what is Alibaba
she said Open Sesame
good so I went on the street ask about
10 20 people they all know about Alibaba
40 thieves and Open Sesame
and I think this is a good name and
start with a whatever you talk about all
the brothers are the top rule number
eight customers are number one we
believe the coke on very different from
the Wall Street we believe custom number
one in pride number two share whenever
first no one employee yeah are we again
this is my religion you know if you it's
the custom that pay us the money it's
the employees that drive the innovation
it's the shareholder in a shareholder
always say you know I thought remember
the day before we IPO and a lot of
people say Jack Aniki but the shares we
were long-term shareholders but when the
crisis came these guys wrong as soon as
you know they were a runaway my people
stayed custom stay rule number nine
don't complain look for opportunities
most people complain where is the
opportunity days people started
complained
some people complain some stuff people
start change themselves changing others
where the opportunities is where they
could place on whether the travel
whereas the opportunity and I was really
that rule number 10 have passion
our team can was a police report from
anything about the whole system million
trillion or their to the city itself is
over here
Roger told is or tech support is really
out to the pizza this support is a
supported
Wallace for solutions and please protect
our generate with the people close until
or the Paraiba acting with you must have
two reports it's an alternative exponent
again dear inner voice Anderson
understood quick decision compatible
with each other to Busan coverage
through Jerusalem - intimate noble will
be talking to you simple particles are
gonna get in Japan okay thank you
the debate will jump to each other the
engine champion tenderness it'll just
take a minute though doesn't where she
won Fanta so we're not that people in it
what incentive is for not being such a
neighboring want you think I don't know
Morgan surrounded him harder public mr.
Joseph omission conscious of and so on
whether he wants credit on the adoption
well in the concern with you on the new
collegiate are gonna be each evaluation
is missile which is when the piece on
the tungsten rhenium visual change
intelligent forms of are good memories
of Michigan the signals are in Venice
reform which even summer so hope all the
on the back we have got a PB kappa our
you can either you can sorry for can I
borrow such because I say we are
actually what you the intern
we never saw the useful content having a
better it's how were you don't they let
you better know who was ironing
limburgian rule number 11 just go for it
mom made it into college on his third
try and became an English teacher with
no computing or engineering background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he says
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touch keyboard before I never
using computer before and I say what is
internet he's a jack and I'll search
whatever you want on the Internet
how can I search what is such me is it
just the type I don't want to type
computer is so expensive in China I
don't want to destroy it he said it's
not a bomb just the type so I tapped the
first work of beer at that time very
slow come out the American beer Japan
beer and the German beer but no China
beer Saul was curious and I was type of
China no China no data came back to Hans
oh we think one dollar in my pocket
scared worried and I came back and I
said I want to do something called
Internet rule number 12 solve big
problems we are not a company that
normally China Khan we call ourselves
accompanied running a platform a company
that is running an ecosystem we are
almost everywhere people say Jack you
know you are in the b2b and b2c and
you're calling CTV on a finance and
online payment logistic cloud computing
you are everywhere not because we're
greedy not because we want to do it
because we have to do it if we cannot if
we do not to do it China ecommerce in
the years will collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that a leap a people say yet don't touch
the financing sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison
and I we taught ourselves if we don't do
it the China ecommerce were always like
like a chat room everybody said it's a
good thing and yeah I don't pay you
don't get the things so I say well put
me in the prism let's make a shirt that
Ali pay the payment solution works and
people say the payment solution is such
a stupid idea it's an escrow service I
pay you hold the money and you get the
things you pay the money if you don't
get the things you want return the money
they say it's a stupid product and I say
as long as I solve the problem I like
stupid things you know let's make stupid
things smart keep on improving every day
rule number 13 change yourself when I
start a business cuz it's so difficult
to be a small business owner in China
it took me five months to bond five
hundred dollars and still fit no chance
and it is it is and I have no any idea
about how to run a business and I when I
go to register company called Internet
the register officer said no there's no
such a word into the new dictionary
[ __ ] register and internet so they
say you have to register another name
thing it wasn't what's the name is a
computer consulting firm and I have no
idea that what is computer so I first
company's pounds of hope because
computer consulting firm
it was tough was not know anything but
enough technology without knowing
anything but a computer in the past of
fifteen years been working I call myself
like a blind man riding on the back of
the blind Tigers those Esper's riding
horses they all fell we survived
rewarded by the future we believe the
future we change our self we know
completely others need number fourteen
inspire every five years we have a
review for our strategy now our strategy
is always a look at the thirty years and
ten years every strategic decisions we
make we have to ask one question this
decision we make solve society problem
because we believe the bigger social
property you solve the most successful
you are so if we do it this cannot solve
any social problems we don't do it
second is this project is going to be
successful in 10 years if is it's going
to be successful in 10 years let's do it
if it's going to be successful in one
year or one month normally I say forget
about it because why you can be
successful in one year or one mouth so
we all have to put param and five years
ago we had a big debate about 10 years
later 20 years what are the things this
China society the world leave want so we
say happiness and health to H strategy
to happiness and health we believe
hollow do you know the movie industry
bring people happy because today nobody
is happy
rich people not happy poor people not
happy you know at least when I watch
movie are you happy but right so I think
we should have partner with the
Hollywood especially like a lot of you
know we have a different way of living
and in China the movie we have a lot of
heroes but China movies heroes always
dead an American movie hero never die
if all the heroes die who want to be the
hero so my movie I want to make the hero
live alright so this is this is I think
we should learn a lot and it's all about
two years so we have another eight years
ago I want to make our company that it's
it's not ecommerce it's something that
giving people inspirations given people
because I learned a lot for example I
will say that my favorite movie forest
the gum you know life stuff
this is I learned and that inspired me
that is why when people call me crazy
stupid pass the 70 years you're crazy I
tell you something never work
you're stupid how can you that model
Emma's in this model eBay this model why
help about this model I told myself
Forester come set for a hat I would care
about what the other people and the
other thing forest come said nobody make
money out of the catching whales people
make money by catching shrimps so we
serve small business remember 15 will
trust with your customers we studied the
e-commerce nobody believed that China
would have ecommerce because people
believe on the one she face-to-face and
all kinds of networking traditional ways
there's no trusted system in China he
had to overcome centuries of tradition
by showing Chinese buyers and sellers
that they could trust
Alibaba with their money in this new
virtual world he did it by guaranteeing
the transactions and creating his own
payment system an escrow account where
Alibaba holds the buyers money until the
goods are delivered every day we finish
more than 13 minute rands actions and
that means that there you are buying
things from somebody you have never seen
you are giving products to the person
you have never met and there are some
guys you never know they
is gonna take your products to that
place to that person I want to tell the
people that trust is there because it's
all about it's all about the trust
number 16 work smart who works harder
the people at eBay are the people of
Alibaba sometimes you have not only have
to work how you have to work smart
mm-hmm
so would you say you work smarter than I
pay I'd have to say yes right well it's
so far yeah so so far okay because
because I think you know we are pretty
lucky people and the people see you yeah
you work very hard
chew in this or that so many people work
very hard but they're not that I told my
team when we I'd pill I asked a lot of
people sitting there I say you know all
of you guys motovlog I millionaires and
so rich but 15 years ago who are we
it's so difficult for us to hide people
15 years ago people who are not that bad
I said people can walk still walk on we
hide them here is nobody believed
Internet of I believe internet and they
join a company those people who believe
they're smart they were had hunted back
to the other country they set up their
own company those people no nobody go to
hell Huntingdon this state today the big
successful very rupee reasons we exist
will persist we never give up we believe
the dreams together rule number 17
believe in your philosophy one of the
things that's so fascinating to me is
that Amazon or Jeff Bezos have pursued
what might be described as a very asset
heavy business model they're buying
airplanes they want to own the entire
supply chain from beginning to end and
Alibaba
has effectively an asset like business
it is very much in terms of the retail
piece of this the opposite you don't
want to own the warehouses you don't
want to own the logistics companies how
do you think about that is Jeff Bezos
right or are you right and is there is
there going to be a meeting in the
middle I hope both are right
and because the world can never have a
one model if the world has only one
corrector model there was too boring
alright we need to have all kinds of
models and the people who do the bottle
should believe in the model and I
believe what I do right the difference
between Amazon and us everything is more
like an empire everything they should
control themselves buy and sell and our
philosophy is that we want to be a
ecosystem our philosophy is to empower
others to sell empower others to sit to
service empower making sure the other
people are more powerful than us making
sure with the our technology our
innovation our partners ours 10 very
small business sellers they can compete
with Microsoft IBM our philosophy is
that we we think using Internet
technology we can make every company
become Amazon real number 18 think
carefully
I learned my English by myself every
morning from 5 o'clock
I rode a bicycle about 40 minutes to the
Hanzel hotel looking for 40 toys to
teach in the English I told show them
around the city to amaze reached my age
not a perfect but a things I learned so
interesting because the things Americans
the for enjoyment of China I mean it
told me I'm so different from the things
I learned from my parents and my
teachers I was in cultural revolution
everything I taught so different since
then everything I've learned I've got to
have it you have to think use your own
brain to think about just one more
minute
when everything thought is it yes wait
for one minute where everybody no wait
for women
think about it carefully because if you
look at the world in a different way you
might do in a different way
rule number 19 focus on the efficiency
in the future people you will not make
company but make money by the service
you offer good service you you do it's
going to be how efficient you are and
Alibaba we we our company right now have
20 does not including the Financial
Group we have a 25 units 25 different
business units maybe in the future we
might have 50 I don't know right we have
done many units and we are almost in
everywhere we control our head counts by
efficiency we have we only have to 24 to
the 4000 people I tell your story last
the thing I feel proud of the two years
ago we we start to have a budgeting
meeting and I asked my team
well year 2012 if we want to double all
the numbers we have how many people we
need and people say seven thousand eight
hundred new people and it's a no no no
check it again and then they say 600 and
800 people as you know and they might my
people asking you how many you want
I said 200 there's no impossible 200 my
answer is are four years we discussed we
should hire more people for future I've
heard this for 10 years now let's let's
let's just do the efficient thing and I
told all the management if we have net
income net you know had done over 200
Eva one people we should have no bonus
for a whole year for year 2012 and then
we started stat the plan year 2012 we
never lose 1,000 people or the number
doubled and I say if we want to create
more jobs for the others
let's keep our head accounts make sure
because right now we have over
500 minute register users on top up no
matter how many people we hire ourself
we cannot be it's always not enough
people so we can focus on technology
focusing on making sure the platform its
efficiency focusing everybody makes the
difference in the platform that will
make the difference
rule number 20 enjoy your life people
say oh this is unscented ursa to world
everyday sir settle the only certain day
was yesterday
I'm not sure about that
in the future I think I would dictate
our be stupid that's why I should retire
early when I'm young that is why I have
a lot of things that a dream I want to
do I want to throughout the day I want
to be a teacher I want to go back to
school I want to do the environment and
the world is so wonderful why should be
the sea of olive all the time I'm coming
to this world not to work I want to come
to this sort to enjoy my life I don't
want to die my office I'm gonna die on
the beaches it's a wonderful message
remember 21 learn from the mistakes of
others my thinking is that you guys
remember if you want to be successful
learn from the other people's mistakes
don't learn from the successful stories
successful stories they may don't listen
to that there are a lot of reasons
behind it just like God I remember the
first time Harvard Business School came
to us say J we want to write a case
study for you yes years 2001 a 2000
became this spend one week and they
write a report and I read now I said
this is not me and this is this is you
as a no this is not us is that this is
you so they make IV sign and the case
study go up and they start to teaching
love universities the next of five years
they invited me to go to the case study
and they always find a competitor of my
company and F after every case that case
study Ali Papa would died that company
will
succeed all the students are green and
actually every five years all the
competitive diet ways to survive so how
can you study this kind of a success of
a star learn from the mistakes the other
people no matter how smart you are you
will encounter these mistakes you learn
from mistakes not because you will be
able to avoid mistakes you were able to
when these mistakes come they suffer
comes you know how to deal with it how
to face it
I write the book I want to write if I if
I want if I can
it's a re Bubber 1001 mistake this is
the most rational things that in my life
in my life is not how much we achieved
is how much we go through the tough days
and mistakes and this is what you see if
you step to think now would be good rule
number 22 focused on quality not size
last a century the bigger the better
this century the good the better do the
business not because the size it is not
necessary the big size you are the more
profit you are you really believe that I
believe that's a different we have you
know we got a fortune 500 companies you
you judge because of the size how many
of them are really happy how many of
them profit no small companies they're
very profitable they're very happy
because spend time was the wife and a
husband and kids traveling around and
what's the life
rule number 23 be the first dog tried to
beat the best
be the first be the first to change be
the first to check the challenge be the
first one to overcome the difficulties
because the best person there's only one
Olympic champion I don't think I'm lucky
enough to be bad but I can always try
the new things and don't give I believe
it because you you are so unique
everybody's unique be yourself is always
the key rule number 24 prepare for the
future people like me I was born in a
very poor family I never got a great
education and I failed all the
examinations for what reason I don't
know but later I realize I don't have
money I don't have technology I don't
have a lot of good backgrounds where we
have a rich uncle or something no they
only that competed with my people then
if young people is less competed for ten
years later this is what I believe ten
years later will be happening so
everything I do for that goal
I know ten years later this thing is
going to happen
so prepare for that because I know if I
compete with him for next Mouse no
chance so this is how my message is up
it's a challenge but it's opportunity
and it's the opportunity for people like
us this world the most difficult to
thing is to convincing a successful
people wait tell him this is a great
opportunity to nananananana forget it
right I've been doing this for thirty
years but for people like us we're
looking for opportunities in order to
survive so we will do anything to be
creative so this is the message thirty
years it's opportunity for us it's a
challenge for those people who are 60
years old if they're 60 years old
not discrimination but it is tough for
them
rule number 25 respect your customers
who's your most dangerous competitor is
it Amazon or is it ten-second well
people always think compare us with
Emma's Evers a great company
I respect I've been seeing them from
tiny to that big and I think they will
continue to grow but we are different we
Emerson is an e-commerce company we are
not ecommerce company we enable other
people to do ecommerce we want to making
sure everybody can be Amazon so you
saying $0.10 is the greater term is of
course they're great a company and you
know it's it's not easy to be that size
within only such less than 30 years so
innovative and so creative are so
different on social technology and
they're basting set the intention and
they're almost every way in China or
respect of course we compete but compete
does not mean I have to hate them don't
hate your competitors respect your
competitors learn from him but you know
pony and I we've been doing the charity
together the Nature Conservancy and
protected the org but we compete each
other but when we compete each other we
should respect each other I respect him
I respect him cent rule number 26 see
challenges as opportunities this world
today's a full of challenges and
opportunities 2,000 years ago full of
challenges and opportunities and I'm
sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there is always it depends on how you
look at
somebody look at this challenge as
opportunity young people we say there's
no opportunity I complain a lot when I
was young because I think Bill Gates
took odd opportunities for the Microsoft
and Steve Jobs all these guys there's no
job there's no great big stuff left for
us but I think opportunity always lies
in the challenges always lies in the
complaints if you can solve the
challenge you have there you will be
successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the the big opportunity you
have rule number 27 believe in the past
18 years when I do internet in China we
got a criticism every day you know
something will you believe it a lot of
people criticize it but if you really
believe continue to do it
improve it we were rejected by more than
30 venture capitalists but we are very
optimistic we believe in the future we
believe in Internet and we believe that
if we do not succeed
somebody will rule number 28 surround
yourself with greatness how do i emote -
by incentive unlock by by our colleagues
you have to find the people we can
mobilize themselves it's impossible to
find - to encourage an active person so
the people your high that people work
together they they have to be oh you
cannot we have a 65,000 in price now you
cannot high all of them that positive
but at least the people work with me my
management leadership several areas they
have to be positive they have to know
the incentive the others because I
cannot accept everybody and making sure
the culture so
I think it would be very painful for me
to talk to my vice president and he need
to be incentivized and mobilized every
time right this won't work if he is not
if he does not know how to incentivize
or mobilize his people it's better I
don't think he will be the vice
president they should be a good engineer
good designer but not good leader a good
leader should know how but not by only
money most of people incentive lies or
move on not because you give them a lot
of money you give the respect trust
appreciation and correct heartful advice
when it come to my meetings internal
meetings you will be shocked because we
we're not like a lot of other Chinese
company the boss they ever listen take
notes and going down we are like a war
room we make this issue based on whose
voice is louder early days you know
spider the talk and then making sure
everybody speak up right so this is also
a way of mobile life and incentives
there are a lot of ways and different
people have a different way to send
incentive
rule number 29 live healthy I think life
is a journey you come to this world is
to enjoy the life to be happy and
healthy so the day when you leave the
world and say I'm happy in my life my
health in this life because if you're
not healthy you will never be happy so I
believe happy and healthy are the things
the human being always looking for and I
think
next to 30 years because of the
technology people the life science is
gonna change a lot and people is gonna
live longer but we can live longer
that's not necessary live healthier so
if you're not healthy how can you be
happy if you live longer if you're not
happy while you live there rule number
30 have fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
rule number 31 get used to being
challenged people like us we are getting
used to be criticized we're getting used
to be said no people say no to you when
people say yes to you we're really
appreciate because it's not you know why
people should say yes to you you have to
prove
so as the Aintree premier you have to
get used to be challenged have to get
used to be said no by the other people
by the fountain by the investors by your
customers by the people but this this is
the opportunity when everybody believe
it
you have no chance we're only a few
people believe it you believe it you
prove it that's your chance remember 30
to adapt to change
so they OPM watch as an engineer the
cheap way well digger Shing cut system
she won cotton piano or path take a
tongue Joshua what 22 young she doesn't
know what young young returns of God why
didn't we put them to Jessica treat
other times
Tyra was she a super was the chaplain so
the super earth was it's insane how you
a suggestion at hand and I said we're
here just watch what well that's this
year I yeah you know it simply she about
you when she appeared with you haha and
there's a determination D'Amato cry yeah
instance um what efficient she's saying
psycho piano others today needs your she
knew you Shapiro ha
oh we're totem of and it would be a
while it is maybe when you feel holidays
you know you quit
rule number 33 never give up as a young
boy I never thought you know it is a
young but if ever today I never thought
I would be here honestly I never thought
but as a young boy I probably when I
look back every problems I met invite
when I was a kid benefited me
I filled so many times people probably
know that I've applied jobs for so many
jobs over 30 jobs already
have not even got a chance 24 of us are
interview for a KFC job 23 accepted I
was the only got rejected 6 people went
fuller looking for a police job 5 except
I was the only one my cousin I applied
job as a as a server in a full style to
my city we wait a long queue for 2 hours
he was accepted I really really so my
mother looked at me huh you know yes but
I know this is a training course for me
before my 30 years old I'm a failure of
people lose by never give up I think
there is opportunity there and then I I
was a teacher later I'd read from
University I was teaching the universe
for 6 years
number 5 because number 5 year I was
elected the best a teacher of my
universe elected by students
so I said everything I taught my
students are the things I learned from
books what if I go out spend a 10 years
experience all the things rather fail or
succeed I'd go back to teach again that
was my original thing and doing Alibaba
so I never thought I could be rich I
never thought it would be successful I
never thought we could survive for 18
years and then we made it
rule number 34 try hard I think
everybody can be successful if you
really try try a hard I study Alibaba
1999 in my apartment I talked to the
18th founders that one thing we want one
of the things who want to prove if Jack
- team can be successful 80% of the
people in the world they can be
successful because we don't have money
would have technology we don't have
almost nothing the only thing is that we
believe in the future and instead to do
little by little
rule number 35 don't plan think of what
some of you share core business plan ok
Julie it's Hamilton make a loan to the
soul raymond laté yes or Tom Vallely
woman watch your children you can walk
away question on the on a larger scale
of a business pleasure Raisman is a
Silicon Valley paying a function notice
or no pass anita guha from took a potato
potato on a hold your major purpose is
playing with children you ain't your
lunatic in New Hampshire
she internet a business plan Yaman is a
chicken thoughts is a hominid that she
can do G they could posit aquifers a
messaging Yoshi efficient owns the
initial I can detail the plan it's
recurrent Nativity what siddhappa stuff
well so I am be a Stanford MBA KCMO
calendar why you ma Pocoyo Flair
young-shin doncha so let's ask why you
debar so you know we'll hold you the
plenty of pressure what measures in just
a couple mm and the decisions you more
PMOI this film has a three hot a plan
doesn't its appeal to Genesis you the
function rule number 36
don't worry about competition when you
do business
don't worry about competition there's
nowhere in this world there's no
competition you have to get used to it
not a stop to oblige they ship the world
is getting so small if you cannot stop
it improve it
about the competition today it's like a
10,000 meters of running for the first
200 meters don't think that guy is the
competitor keep on running 3,000 meters
later you were no force competitor rule
number 37 focus on your customers and
team spending time all your customers
spend time or your people on your own
team don't spend time I investors don't
spend time are your competitors when you
look at the people you want to surf wait
look at the people you work together if
they're happy you will win that's the
very simple remember 38 higher your
weaknesses so what's in Buddhism
well touching he awaits happening back
coding since I'm researching what our
Chilean weights take a high Celtic put
on to Kulemin party so cheese with some
cuts will add POC or even tell what you
put on cheese soup attorney the
potential jeez hey aladin McConnachie
Susan your converts hodja hodja to avoid
salsa senior that's gonna be too awkward
you leave at all they were woman made
Fatah jeong-ja so what'd you do the an
alleged the constants the pages you see
you watch important if so three singing
the CSS Co bottle Jason Lobo Co hard on
chisel Kenya to the Nepean anyway a
kebab they were they were cutting a
tomato can Tameka Europa's organs Ibaka
Serena Warren King at the concert hammer
Regina is what they were because they
come to fight anyway Mary Carter my
super shape mayor you're coding sewage
and her person touching changing each
analyst and gentlemen Darien what you
this Taman but take a soil water and
here comes a peon tenacious courses show
Mike respect to the soy contains the
cinnamon capital city water so vision
vision poopy intentions
aventure imagine the pizza needs of our
business yes so you know consensus Alma
console email is the UI soil really any
purpose amici so that we are in sasame
check mommy but no cheese was a
Micronesia Sunnah Johnny Otis Armando
consider consensus hola dahveed she
doesn't watch yet yeah you're a mango a
teacher ha my epitome cheese soup was
also found in seconds and it softens the
map justly Kenya
warehouse craving Darnay huh when your
tunes on they huh
rudabeh 39 be strategic my my view is
that if when you're 20 to 30 years old
you should follow a good boss joining a
good company to learn how to do things
properly when you're 30 to 40 years old
if you want to do something yourself
just do it you're sticking afford to
lose to fail but when you're 40 to 50
years old my suggestion is that you
should do things that you are good at
right
and not do things that oh that's very
interesting I want to try something new
it's be dangers more when you're 50 to
60 years old spending time training and
developing young people the next
generation when you see over 60 years
old better stay with your grandchildren
but this is normally general like that
not everybody like but most of the
people who looked at so 30 years old we
people next to 30 years are the luckiest
a period we're a lot of challenges a lot
of things that's happening and with our
knowledge with our
physical power it's time you need to
change you have to think we all if you
want to be successful tomorrow it's
impossible if you want to be successful
a year later it's impossible but if you
want to win 10 years later you have
chance that is what I think
rule number 40 serve the planet I want
to do education because I was a trained
to be a teacher I feel guilty for only
taught school for 6 years I feel good
about that so that's why I'm talking
everywhere I think of myself CEOs chief
Education Officer try my best to
communicate so in a sec I think China
education system people say the problem
china education is teaching his
knowledge is so good it's uncle to
childhood teaching we're the best
we're not the best in the world go to
any universities Chinese students taking
exams for the best in the Stanford I
think very good they're very good better
e the count of it that they eat the
culture team work these terrible so we
got to put more efforts on that this is
something I want to help the second
environment I worry about the air
pollution the water all these things and
and so that's why I joined the Nature
Conservancy and the other thing that the
infrastructure of the philosophy you
know Bill Gates tried to convince me and
work with Warren Buffett years ago came
to China which had donate every money
and I asked them well how old are you
wallet is 80 I said when I'm 80 I would
donate my money
I'm only 40 what is my what is my front
opee China go to Beijing Shanghai
they're rich police but they are only
small part of China go to the east us
where's the part of China so many poor
terror policies as a business guy
created jobs do more business making
sure people have jobs making sure people
have a life good conditions this is the
key rule number 41 follow your dreams
in my apartment where we started 18
founders and we aim high we have a dream
we say we want to make become the top 10
internet companies or websites in the
world guys at that time we are ranking
several meaning name who is it won't be
number 10 or the top 10 of the world we
want to make this company last 102 years
and we don't know where's our pay next
month well when you're poor if you have
a dreams you never feel poor you know
what we are doing so after we never say
we will be we will win next year or we
win tomorrow we say we will weigh in 10
20 years 19 years past today we are the
top 10 websites coming to the
competition in the world
we number 40 to change your thinking
African desert ever agree is that the
eCos is not controlled by lions and
elephants the ecosystem is controlled by
the insects in the mud last century the
company the big the better
so everybody want to be a big company
the powerful company this century from
now a good company is more important a
powerful company where you compete to
its become I think in past 20 years
within completing with any company lots
of companies in China but I learned one
thing no matter how strong an elephant
is if you're an ant if you hide yourself
well an elephant cannot kill you you can
kill the elephant
if you're in a better way it's about
your thinking
rule number 43 don't wait for luck
pinchy face hudsonia mei-ling she
sobered outside here tanning system
bladder so what the ravine support so
that also pinches Avila needs an inches
higher is anxious to shower so soon that
were Mia really were 44 get used to be
rejected our first IP year's year 2007
when Alibaba IPO in Hong Kong year 2007
we are a lot of millionaires in the
company and I asked my friend my
colleagues alike we have like a 300
people become millionaires and I asked
them a now tell me you become
millionaires because you are smarter
than the others
the people said no no no we even cannot
find the jobs because you are
hardworking yes we were happy we find
more people hard-working than us but
they do not succeed
one of why they're not smart all the
smart people at that time they went to
Microsoft and IBM and headhunting
companies came to head and all the best
guy from us and we are the people nobody
cut the head on us we have no place to
go
we believe in ourself we believe our
dream will work together so I say we are
the people because nobody want us I am
the person over 30 companies don't want
to make right so we are the people get
used to be rejected
we are the people get used to be say no
from the other people why people should
help you people help you that is unusual
people do not help you that is very
common you should work to earn to be
helped rule number 45 prove your worth
KFC has refused to hire you so
with all these know how at the end of
the day what has been the driver which
has made you who you are
yeah I wish people can say yes to me but
if they say yes I have no choice I think
accept it and of course you're not happy
when people say no have a good sleep
wake up try it again
it's always my fault not the other
people spot why you can convince people
if you cannot prove it but the thing is
that very important there to group of
people you have to convincing first
group people your team they believe in
you they trust in you and they believe
the things we agree together and second
is your customers they really love your
products and investors it's okay rumor
46 be resourceful for that she take
Suchong yeah
at all watching abu qamha analysis and
watch a GUI or console this has links to
go so he can show you this a 1 kg omaha
really function to occur know what this
job well the teams in this of kerkovich
are so you were colony migratory Haddad
Toyota's the opposite emerge here are
see with hydrogen even if you do change
each event Idaho Sagan either when he
Gmail where we can kill Devon Tito
possible chances achieve key event ID
katsumata so tamari soy Honduran so
voyage had okay can take a cigarette she
participates on taking Casillas
apologizing so it's a Dutch engine wait
Alibaba consent son gokû noir such as
Yahoo Rwandan take a change in survey
sample atole Jacobsen only each about
say and days of fungal vomit even on a
young and under segregation Caledonia
django Django China each aku so the
changes are you go Puerta de Jun de
pacheco that's a biodome BTU
the champion Roja
yo-yo chant OGG
see war machine Seneca rule number 47
never complain
that's entrepreneur we never complain we
make other people complain we make our
competitors complain
we never cry because if cry can solve
the problems okay so no problem we make
competitors cry we make those people who
do not believe our dreams cry
rule number 48 embrace the change I
think people worry about jobs today with
the people worried about artificial
intelligence
well don't worry too much about that
people are improving and people working
about a security eleva but God in the
past of five years every day we got a
300 million attacks per day but we think
the opportunity let's learn it let's
learn how to do it solve the problems
and then in the future where we've got
the experience share with the others
that's the whole thing so I want to get
encouraging everybody look at the future
we cannot avoid it we have to embrace
him where to live it think about the
future and there are a lot of things my
grandfather will never be surprised we
would be so surprised that today human
being have so many jobs can be created
rule number 49 Act Sheila Davalloo Liam
Jovian was a 100 sessions at you some
better Hanzo server G hey philu the
Kenichi are inside toning the engine
Graham why a miserable going about the
muscle if I end up good cinema bar where
you can't sometimes you coochie Papa
boring yeah well your chilavert switch
into thoughts which is sorry I'm carry
your machines ha
the girlfriend on your home meet other
teams had their war - you will not
release younger on the heating guy Chang
ji tenure hives
they work in the green engine carry ing
me me against God or jeweller somebody
has to stop them so what your quick
watches silicates in design has equality
gingers are or animal I get happy with
Shi Tao common [ __ ] in can over here
well I'm certain the song called up was
your way apart
[Music]
and why a personality your shoes and you
get a package [ __ ] so to learn a legal
interest when you saw some math oh yeah
what hey Pamela what you saw car engine
turns engine to engine get visual
analogy Halawa the other hand jet on
kalla pinay you got sushi Angie you're
not having a guy you got her soon hey
Nate Havana - so was a hundred very
political Sicilian cigars or whichever
Ching hua Xiong trigger has a mile east
of the city of the Sahara such a surface
on Telugu knee put stitches hatchet in
charge of the shin don't take opium ha
Connie Meg when she ruin needs Hank
addition don't need Joe Cronin's is a
goddamn part of the Soul Eater and rule
number fifty the last one before a very
special bonus clip is find your home
1999 we study the business and people
ask why not a Beijing shahe why Hangzhou
I mean no Hangzhou is this hub of
entrepreneurs and startups and tech but
back then back then hunters nowhere and
and I think at that time Nokia was so
good at that time and I say guys where's
Nokia he's a thing there's some small
island headquarters there it's not where
you are I don't see it's where your
heart is where your vision is so we said
Beijing they love SOE stayed on the
business
Shanghai to love multinational companies
IBM Microsoft the embrace your startup
entrepreneur forget it right so I said
if in Beijing where nobody in Shanghai
where nobody if we go to back to handle
where the only child of the local family
Oh stutters now I have a special bonus
tip from Jack on how to be a true leader
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching the video to taking
action here we go
question number one what's the first
weakness that you need to hire for
number two where do you need to focus on
quality instead of size and number three
what's the big problem that you are
trying to solve and if you like this
video and will take action after
watching it give me a hash tag believe
down the comments as well I found out
some great leaders in the world they are
always positive they never complained
others and never complain and they they
look at the things in a different view
like normal people so I think people a
my company they at the beginning they
don't like me because I'll always think
about ten years five years and then
after we working together for three or
five years they find out who you are
right then we got the credit rating and
as a CEO one of the jobs where
everybody's happy you have to see the
unhappy things when everybody's unhappy
you have to see the happy things so
leadership is nature but you have to
have a train and learn and I got my
leadership sub upgraded in Davos I see
so many were you know on the end to
financing how many people here know
about Ari pay thank you ally pays
decision was made here I was thinking
about Ally paid you know but I was not a
dare to launch a leap it because in
China if you do financing with
unlicensed you were being jailed at that
time so I say I went to the banks can
help us do the e-commerce of transaction
no no no no banks would accept it so if
there will be no a leap in no financing
the e-commerce to go nowhere so I was
year 2002 for
I was here listen to a speech by two
state leaders about leadership and this
guy's leadership is about responsibility
you believe it but don't be that people
don't believe it but if you think is so
critical
you should pay any price to do it so
that day changed my mind and a call back
to my team say let's launch it within
one month if somebody else go to the
jail I go to the gym who would be the
second we'll follow me if I go you
continue you go to the jail you will
continue that was the code the
leadership determination and year 2004 I
made a decision here I called back and
now today the Alipay launched int it's
so big over you know 800 million people
today using a leap a globally this is
called if you want to learn nine
surprising facts about Jack Ma check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there for nine years
every morning almost no weather snow
rain or Sun I went there looking for
foreign tourists to become the free
guide